>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, WELCOME
TO TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
ONE THING ABOUT AMERICANS, THEY
LOVE AUSTRALIA.
MOST AMERICANS HAVE NEVER BEEN
THERE.
IT'S A LONG WAY AWAY.
BUT WHEN AMERICANS THINK OF
AUSTRALIANS, THEY IMAGINE A
FREER, TOUGHER VERSION OF
THEMSELVES.
STEVE ERWIN, CROCODILE DUNDEE,
THAT KIND OF THING.
SO A HUGE RESERVE OF AFFECTION
IN THE UNITED STATES FOR
AUSTRALIA, IT'S CULTURE, AND
IT'S PEOPLE.
IT'S ALSO POSSIBLE THAT MOST
AMERICANS HAVE NOT UPDATED OUR
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT AUSTRALIA IN A
WHILE AND THE REALITY IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE
IMAGINED.
CASE IN POINT, TWO YEARS AGO,
JUNE, 2019, THE FEDERAL POLICE
IN SYDNEY RAIDED THE OFFICES OF
THE AUSTRALIAN BROADCASTING
CORPORATION, THE AUSTRALIAN
BROADCASTER, ABC.
THEY WERE NOT UNCLEAR AT ALL
ABOUT WHY THEY RAIDED.
THEY SAID IT OUT LOUD.
DAYS BEFORE THE RAID, ABC
BROADCAST ALLEGATIONS OF A
WHISTLEBLOWER THAT EMBARRASSED
THE GOVERNMENT OF AUSTRALIA.
THE MILITARY LEADERS HAD KILLED
CIVILIANS IN AFGHANISTAN
INCLUDING CHILDREN AND HAD LIED
ABOUT IT.
THE ABC BROADCAST, THAT STORY,
IT WASN'T A CRIME TO BROADCAST
THE STORY IN AUSTRALIA'S POLICE
DIDN'T PRETEND IT WAS.
INSTEAD, THEY SERVED THE
BROADCASTER FROM THE WARRANT
THAT AUTHORIZED THEM, THE
POLICE, TO COVER UP ANY EVIDENCE
OF THE AUSTRALIA MILITARY'S
MISCONDUCT.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MINUTE.
THE WARRANT, WE'RE QUOTING IT,
ALLOWED THE POLICE TO QUOTE,
ADD, COPY, DELETE, OR ALTER ANY
MATERIAL THEY WANTED TO ALTER ON
THE BROADCASTER'S COMPUTER.
THAT'S NOT THE KIND OF THING
HAPPENS IN A FREE COUNTRY TO PUT
IT MILDLY.
BUT YET AUSTRALIA'S POLICE
FORCES NEVER SUFFERED
CONSEQUENCES FOR DOING IT.
MANY AUSTRALIANS, THE POLLS
SHOW, SUPPORTED IT.
THEY AWARDED THE MILITARY WITH
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
MOST OF IT WAS TO KEEP THE
AUSTRALIAN'S SAFE FROM THE
MALIGNING INFLUENCE OF THE
CHINESE AUTHORITARIANISM.
EVEN THOUGH IT SEEMED A LOT LIKE
CHINESE AUTHORITARIANISM ITSELF.
TWO YEARS LATER?
WHAT DOES AUSTRALIA LOOK LIKE?
IT LOOKS LIKE CHINA AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC.
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
PEOPLE WERE WELDED INSIDE OF
THEIR APARTMENTS TO STARVE, THE
GUYS IN HAZMAT SUITS FORCING
PEOPLE TO QUARANTINE BOXES AND
DRIVING AWAY TO SOME UNKNOWN
DESTINATION.
AT THE TIME, OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS, INCLUDING TONY FAUCI
SAID NOTHING LIKE THAT COULD
HAPPEN IN OUR COUNTRY OR IN THE
WEST.
BUT THAT WAS WRONG.
BECAUSE THOSE THINGS ARE NOW
HAPPENING IN AUSTRALIA. THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS IN AUSTRALIA, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF YOU TRY TO LEAVE
YOUR APARTMENT.
>> ANTHONY KNOWS HE'S COVID
POSITIVE WHEN HE STEPS INTO THE
PUBLIC LIFT, ALREADY BREAKING SO
MANY RULES, HE DOESN'T BOTHER TO
COVER HIS MOUTH AS HE SNEEZES
AND SPLATTERS.
THE 27-YEAR-OLD IS STILL
INFECTIOUS, BUT HAS GONE MISSING
FROM HIS WENTWORTH POINT
APARTMENTS.
A WARRANT NOW ISSUED FOR HIS
ARREST.
>> THIS 27-YEAR-OLD CHAP WHO
APPARENTLY HAS EXPRESSED THE
VIEW THAT HE DOESN'T CARE
WHETHER HE SPREADS THE VIRUS IS
ONE EXAMPLE OF THE WORST OF THE
WORST.
>> Tucker: SO, A NATIONAL HAN
HUNT FOR -- MAN HUNT FOR A MAN
WHO SNEEZED IN AN ELEVATOR.
THAT'S THE STATE OF PLAY IN
AUSTRALIA.
NOT EVERYONE IN THE COUNTRY IS
ONBOARD BY THIS.
BECAUSE THEY WERE DISARMED BY
THE GOVERNMENT SEVERAL YEARS
AGO, THERE'S NOTHING THEY CAN DO
ABOUT IT.
IT'S ACCELERATED.
LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
THEY'RE BEING CRUSHED.
THIS WAS THE SCENE IN MELBOURNE,
THE SECOND MOST POPULOUS CITY IN
THE COUNTRY IN THE PAST MONTH.
WATCH.
>> WE'RE TRYING TO GET -- HOME.
WE'RE ING GET HOME.
>> Tucker: THE GOVERNMENT
CRACKING DOWN ON EXTREMISTS?
NO, JUST ORDINARY AUSTRALIANS
DEMONSTRATING PEACEFULLY AGAINST
THE LOCKDOWNS, BEATEN BY POLICE.
THERE'S A LOT OF FOOTAGE LIKE
THIS FROM AUSTRALIAMENT. IN A
MOMENT, WE'LL SHOW YOU MORE.
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
IMMEDIATELY OBVIOUS FROM THE
AMERICAN VANTAGE IS THIS ISN'T
ALL OF AUSTRALIA, THE WHOLE
COUNTRY IS NOT LOCKED DOWN.
IN AUSTRALIA, MOST OF THE
LOCKDOWNS ARE ON THE EASTERN
PART OF THE COUNTRY, WHERE THE
CAPITAL IS, WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS THE MOST CONTROL.
THE WESTERN PART, THE WEST
POPULATED PART OF AUSTRALIA,
MEANWHILE, HOME TO THE COUNTRY'S
NATIONAL RESOURCES ISN'T LOCKED
DOWN AT ALL.
50,000 FANS JUST CROWDED INSIDE
OF A STADIUM FOR A RUGBY MATCH
FOR PERTH, THE CAPITAL OF
WESTERN AUSTRALIA, NO ONE WAS
BEATEN WITH KNIFE STICKS OR
HOSED BY THE POLICE.
IT WAS NOT A SUPER SPREADER
EVENT.
WESTERN AUSTRALIA HAD VIRTUALLY
NO CASES OF COVID.
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
HOW DOES WESTERN AUSTRALIA NOT
LOCK DOWN BUT REMAIN VIRTUALLY
COVID FREE?
SIMPLE?
BY CONTROLLING THE BORDERS.
WESTERN AUSTRALIA DID NOT LET
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE STREAM IN
FROM ANYWHERE THEY WANTED TO IN
THE WORLD, THEY'RE NOT TEXAS.
THEY DIDN'T CARE ABOUT
PROTECTING THE BORDERS.
THEY'RE RACIST.
IT SEEMED COMMON SENSE, IT
WORKED.
HERE'S THE REVEALING THING.
IN AUSTRALIA, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ANGRY THAT WESTERN
AUSTRALIA HAS CLOSED IT'S
BORDERS.
THEY WANT THAT PART OF THE
COUNTRY TO OPEN THOSE BORDERS.
REALLY?
WHY WOULD THAT BE?
WELL, ACCORDING TO ABC NEWS,
AUSTRALIA IS ARGUING THAT THE
WESTERN BORDER RESTRICTIONS ARE
A DRAG ON THE NATIONAL AUTONOMY,
END QUOTE.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
BECAUSE THE PROBLEM WITH THE
AUSTRALIA ECONOMY RIGHT NOW
DOESN'T COME FROM WESTERN
AUSTRALIA CLOSING THE BORDERS,
IT COMES FROM THE LOCKDOWNS.
THOSE ARE THE BIGGEST DRAG ON
THE NATIONAL ECONOMY EVER
CONCEIVED IN AUSTRALIA.
SO ARE THE POLICE S.W.A.T. TEAMS
BEATING PEOPLE FOR GOING
OUTSIDE.
COVID MANDATES ARE A FAR GREATER
THREAT TO AUSTRALIA'S ECONOMY
AND THE SOCIAL FABRIC THAN COVID
ITSELF. HERE'S THE HEALTH
MINISTER IN QUEENSLAND IN
EASTERN AUSTRALIA EXPLAIN THAT
OUTDOOR MASK MANDATES ARE
NECESSARY BECAUSE OF TWO NEW
COVID CASES, THAT'S TWO, NOT
200,000 OR 2,000.
BUT TWO.
WATCH?
>> WHAT THESE TWO NEW CASES MEAN
IS WE'LL BE EXTENDING THE
DIRECTIVE IN RELATION TO MASK
WEARING TO THE GOLD COAST.
>> Tucker: OKAY, WE WANT TO
PAUSE TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
SCOPE OF THE PANDEMIC IN
AUSTRALIA.
TO DATE, COVID HAS CAUSED 1300,
QUOTE, RECORDED DEATHS IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
AUSTRALIA HAD 25 MILLION PEOPLE.
NOW, THAT 1300 FIGURE INCLUDES
PEOPLE WHO DIED WITH PROBABLE
COVID?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WE HAVE NO IDEA.
NO ONE HAS EVER DEFINED IT.
IN ALBERTA,  CANADA, THIS MIGHT
TELL YOU SOMETHING, ANYONE WHO
STAYS HOME FROM ANY ILLNESS
WOULD BE COUNT BID THE
GOVERNMENT AS A COVID PATIENT.
THEN SHE PRETENDED SHE DIDN'T
SAY IT BECAUSE IT'S INSANE, BUT
IT'S ON VIDEO, SO WE KNOW SHE
DID.
AUSTRALIA ADOPTED A SIMILAR
STANDARD.
ANYONE WHO LEAVES HOME IS
APPARENTLY COUNTED AS A COVID
PATIENT.
A MAN IN MELBOURNE THIS SUNDAY
WHO MADE A MISTAKE OF WALKING A
BLOCK FROM HIS HOUSE.
>> HE LIS A BLOCK AWAY.
>> HE HAS NO REASON TO BE HERE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A REASON TO BE
OUT TODAY.
>> HOLD ON, HE HAS A FACEMASK IN
HIS POCKET.
HE WAS SMOKING A CIGARETTE.
HE CAME TO GET LUNCH WITH ME.
>> I'M HAVING A CIGARETTE.
I HAVE TWO MASKS IN MY POCKET.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU WANT ME TO DO?
>> Tucker: THE INTERESTING
THING, THE AUTHORITARIANISM,
THAT'S TERRIFYING IT CAN HAPPEN
IN AN ENGLISH SPEAKING COUNTRY,
IN AUSTRALIA OF ALL PLACES.
HE NEVER ASKED THE MAN IF HE'S
BEEN VACCINATED.
THAT'S THE FIRST QUESTION THEY
WOULD ASK BECAUSE VACCINATION
WORKS, DOESN'T IT?
THAT'S WHY IT'S MANDATORY,
RIGHT?
THE LEADERS ARE PRETENDING THAT
THE VACCINATION STATUS MATTERS
IN NEW SOUTH WALES, EASTERN
AUSTRALIA.
THE UNVACCINATED WILL BE ALLOWED
TO RETAIN THEIR FREEDOMS.
>> THE MESSAGE TO THE
UNVACCINATED IS YOU WILL NOT
ACHIEVE FURTHER FREEDOM UNLESS
YOU GET VACCINATED.
THE FURTHER AND FINAL MESSAGE TO
REGIONAL NEW SOUTH WALES AND IT
WILL BE INDIVIDUALS WHO CHOOSE
NOT TO BE VACCINATED WHO WILL
LOSE THEIR FREEDOMS ON THE 11th
OF OCTOBER.
>> Tucker: NO MORE FREEDOM IF
YOU DON'T GET THE VAX.
BUT THEY WILL ARREST YOU FOR
BEING OUTSIDE SMOKING A
CIGARETTE A BLOCK FROM YOUR HOME
WITHOUT A MASK AND NOT EVEN ASK
YOU IF YOU'VE BEEN VACCINATED.
SO, VACCINATION STATUS ISN'T
THAT IMPORTANT AS A HEALTH
MATTER, WOULDN'T THAT BE THE
FIRST QUESTION YOU ASK?
BUT THEY DIDN'T BOTHER.
MEANWHILE, IN THE SAME
AUSTRALIAN STATE, NEW SOUTH
WALES, OFFICIALS ARE TELLING
PEOPLE, WHETHER THEY'RE
VACCINATED OR NOT, THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO GO TO CHURCH.
>> IN THE NAME OF JESUS, IT'S IN
THE CITY OF NEW SOUTH WALES.
>> IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT PASSAGE
THIS PASTOR IS PREACHING FROM,
BUT IT'S NOT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDER.
HIS CHURCH, THE CHRIST EMBASSY
IN BLACKTOWN IS IN LOCKDOWN --
HARD LOCKDOWN.
THERE'S NO QR CODE ON THE DOOR
COSTING THE ORGANIZATION $5,000.
EACH OF THESE 30 ADULT
WORSHIPPERS FINED $1,000.
>> WHETHER IT'S A SOCCER MATCH,
WHETHER IT'S A CHURCH SERVICE,
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU CANNOT -- YOU CANNOT GATHER
AS THEY DID AT BLACKTOWN.
>> Tucker: OH, SO YOU HAVE TO
GET VACCINATED TO HAVE ANY OF
YOUR FREEDOMS.
BUT EVEN IF YOU ARE VACCINATED,
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO GO TO
CHURCH.
SO, WHAT IS THE POINT OF
VACCINATION?
WHY DO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
AUSTRALIA LOCK EVERYBODY DOWN IF
THERE'S NO ACTUAL WAY TO STOP
THE LOCKDOWNS?
AND MORE TO THE POINT, WHY DO
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS IN
WESTERN AUSTRALIA IF CLOSING THE
BORDERS ACTUALLY HAS KEPT THE
POPULATION SAFE?
WELL, THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS
THERE FOR THE SAME REASON THEY
WANT IT HERE.
IN NEW SOUTH WALES, ONE
OFFICIAL, THE STATE'S HEALTH
OFFICER, EXPLAINED IT OUT LOUD.
WATCH.
>> WE WILL BE LOOKING AT WHAT
CONTACT TRACING LOOKS LIKE IN
THE NEW WORLD ORDER -- YES, IT
WILL BE PUBS AND CLUBS AND OTHER
THING IFS WE HAVE A POSITIVE
CASE THERE.
>> Tucker: OH, THE NEW WORLD
ORDER.
SHE SAID IT OUT LOUD.
THIS IS A REALLY INTERESTING
STORY, WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
AUSTRALIA AND WHAT IT MEANS FOR
THE REST OF THE ANGLO SPHERE,
VERY MUCH INCLUDING US, AND
MAYBE THAT'S WHY GLOBALLY MOST
MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS HAVE REFUSED
TO COVER IT.
THAT COMMENT, THE ONE YOU SAW
THE NEW WORLD ORDER GOT BARELY
ANY COVERAGE AT ALL.
ALL OF THE FOOTAGE WE SHOWED YOU
TODAY IS MOSTLY BEING IGNORED IN
THE UNITED STATES, WHY?
IT'S POSSIBLE WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN AUSTRALIA MIGHT BE
INSTRUCTIVE TO US IN THE UNITED
STATES. IN JUST TWO YEARS, THE
AUSTRALIAN POLICE WENT FROM
RAIDING NEWS ROOMS TO BEATING
PEOPLE IN THE STREETS. SO, MAYBE
THE LESSON IS THINGS CAN CHANGE
VERY QUICKLY.
ONE MOMENT, THE ENGLISH-SPEAKING
WORLD IS MOCKING CHINA FOR BEING
DISTAUPE YEAH AND AUTOCRATIC.
THE NEXT MOMENT THEY'RE HUNTI